[Music]
domestic abuse is a cancer on society
it's one which affects millions of
adults and millions more children this
week finally saw the domestic abuse bill
have its first reading in the Commons
whilst containing some good aspects the
bill is a missed opportunity to better
protect and support the child victims of
domestic abuse one feature of the bill
which has created widespread debate is
the proposal to use lie detectors to
monitor offenders initially as a pilot
perpetrators will take the test
three months after prison release and
see it repeated every six months
personally I can't see the controversy
in this any measure that protects
victims of abuse and ultimately saves
lives should be welcomed if people don't
feel safe in their homes because of the
very people supposed to love them then
we as a society have very sadly failed
well Michelle I'm really glad you
brought up this subject I think it's
really really important and I also
welcome the domestic abuse bill that is
now back in Parliament I think that the
idea of lie-detector tests I'm less
welcoming of I'm not sure that that is
necessarily effective and I also think
it's interesting that when women's
organizations or organizations that are
that campaign for better protections
against domestic violence they are
asking for different ways of
strengthening that bill they want to see
things like provisions so that migrant
women are defended because quite often
their status can be used either to
pressure them or might make them fearful
about coming forward they've asked for
guarantees around putting people in
priority lists for accommodation so if
they need to flee a violent home that
it's possible for that to happen one of
the biggest causes of homelessness
in this country is people fleeing
domestic violence so they've asked for
lots of other things that would
strengthen that bill but not necessarily
the lie detection the reason that
because I agree with you I think the
bill fails in lots of areas as I said
particularly surrounding the child
victims of it but when I think when it
comes to lie detectors anyone that's
experienced domestic abuse will know
that at its core often it's manipulation
hugely people that domestically abuses
hugely manipulative and a lie detector
test can be a strong tool they don't
convict just off that by the way they
don't say right you you feel get
yourself back to prison that's not what
they get proposing that would be silly
what they're proposing is that that
would become a tool which forms part of
evidence when looking at whether or not
this person needs to be recalled to
prison for breaching their license Nick
why are you shaking your head at me
because obviously anything that can be
done I'm not stupid anything can be done
that then stop and crack down on to mess
up is to be applauded but I just don't
have the same level of faith and lie
detector tests whatsoever they can these
people who are manipulative apparently
I've never done it but you can actually
train yourself quite easily to beat a
lie detector and and I'm always wary of
laws with unintended consequences and
what you might do and I have no time at
all for someone who has committed to my
series but you could actually because of
a lie detector test get completely wrong
readings about someone who's innocent
I just don't put the same thing by the
way we use this in this country for sex
offenders already and we've sent 160 of
them back to prison in part because of
their lie detector stuff so I'm not
advocating what is on the back well it's
various different things so when you've
been released from prison for domestic
abuse the various different license
conditions attached to you whether it's
I don't know you can't go you can't
contact your former partner or you can't
go here or you can't do this there'll be
various different aspects attached to
you and your license and your conditions
have been in this assignment you might
be left with and most cases are of the
woman being the victim I appreciate not
always but the woman saying he's
threatening me he's stalking me he's
doing this he's ringing me late at night
and he says no I'm not
and this is a person has been released
from prison so it's not just like a
casual you know it's been imprisoned
he's tied up is that she's saying I hope
he hasn't went to you but the other side
what if the person has been reoffending
and and trains himself to beat a
lie-detector test and gets a reading
that he is telling the truth when in
fact he is still beating a woman for
example that's a risk I think it's about
8090 percent or so that they're saying
that these things are accurate and as
I'm saying you wouldn't take it as a
standalone tool and what they're
proposing in this instance is a trial so
they're proposing and taking I think 300
perpetrators over the course of a three
year period and looking at whether or
not this works and if it works and it's
effective then it would be rolled out
nationally and that's the thing that I
agree in support
so I look on the core principle if this
is somebody who knew someone growing up
who was he quite strong victim of this
issue
I've always point anything anything that
we've done but as long as we are assure
that it works and if it's being used as
a trial perhaps but just on the issue of
how bad it can get domestic abuse is a
cancer on society I know but my friend
he used to get into fights at school his
parents would beat him and that just
reinstall this idea of problems are
solved through violence you make your
children worse as a result of it you
create lasting problems that will exist
throughout their lives it is so damaging
just Philips the Labour MP who
campaigned a lot of this has doubts
about a lie-detector look I worry that
actually what it will be used for is to
cut corners when actually when people
are released on bail or unlicensed
actually what we need is good police
responses a responsive police who come
when they're called proper orders there
other restraints for women and their
children against violent perpetrators I
have no idea actually what the benefit
of lie-detector tests are I'm willing to
be proven wrong in this however it just
seems a bit gimmicky to me
I mean that's where I you know we don't
the danger is you put things in just
because that's the fashionable thing to
do whereas actually what you want to do
is to try things test them do proper
research and see if they work or don't
work I've not seen any evidence that lie
detectors are particularly effective yet
their widespread use in America I think
coming back to your point about the kids
the thing is as a child when you
experience domestic abuse
you are tor brought up to survive you
are living in an environment which is so
frightening you're so afraid and you
know you're not sheltered by love you're
contained by fear and then what we then
expect for these children who wouldn't
know a healthy relationship you know if
it stood in front of them you expect
these children to come out of that
environment and go on to conduct healthy
relationships and they struggle and then
when they struggle and often cycles of
abuse get repeated through the
generations and I think this bill it was
such a missed or is still such a missed
opportunity to get interventions into
supporting the children because children
are not just witnesses of domestic abuse
they're victims of it and that for me
yes likely takes us is one thing that we
can agree and disagree with but the
child thing they've missed a trick on
this one and it's sad what would you
like to see in there well I would have
liked to have seen
access to proper services for children
so first of all acknowledge children as
victims because when and I lived in this
environment I charted was affected by
domestic abuse and it was awful and the
damage that that did to me as an adult
is hard for me to explain what it did I
did not understand healthy relationships
I did not understand how to demonstrate
loves that I would you understand a
helpline when you go into an environment
I was on the social services at risk
register as a child when you go into a
home environment where there is domestic
abuse the victim of that is not just the
mom it's the children so you for you
that wasn't well so first of all you
have the acknowledgement that a child is
not just a witness it's a victim that's
the first key thing that's missing from
this the second thing is there should be
provision as where those children can be
whether it's counseling what
is its most basic form counseling where
these children are taken into an
environment where they're helped and
educated and almost read what you need a
rewiring and unless you've experienced
it is hard to comprehend but you need a
rewiring so Council's should be mandated
when you're dealing with a family that's
experiencing abuse you have to provide
facilities for those children to support
like overnight facilities the child
comes you take the child I'm asking from
domestic abuse is we have various
different refuges so often people flee
as a family yeah you flee as a family so
it's not about that it's not about
taking people out it's about helping to
rewire that child's brain any way we
could we could go on and on with this
one can we I'm sure miss young it's a
very moving story and of course for
those of us who didn't have that sort of
background it's I don't think we can
ever fully appreciate it right I think
what we should do now is change the mood
whilst I believe passionately in the
subject we've been discussing I also
believe passionately in the strength of
women I've never liked you
let's talk about paying more taxes only
one winner who yeah I know thank you in
your dreams Dyke
[Music]